public sénat en partenariat avec la ffb
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
benoît hamon est l'invité de l'épreuve
de vérité bonsoir et merci d'avoir
accepté l'invitation de public sénat
avec la fp avec les échos et radio
classique que vous avez lancé votre
mouvement génération pour faire vivre
vos idées bien sûr après la campagne
présidentielle et pour vous interroger
ce soir l'uci le malandain de l' agence
france-presse
bonsoir lucile et jean francis pécresse
bonsoir jambon 6 des échos et de radio
classique et vous répondre et benoît
hamon au cours de cette émission à trois
grandes questions premièrement est ce le
début de la fin de l'état de grâce pour
l'exécutif avec la multiplication des
fronts sociaux on va le voir encore
cette semaine 2 quel est donc votre
espace politique où se situe-t-il enfin
3 la france n'est-elle pas de retour
avec emmanuel macron son leadership qui
lui permet de défendre sa vision de la
mondialisation vous pourrez lui apporter
la vôtre tout à l'heure et c'est parti
pour 45 minutes avec la première
question
[Musique]
la première question posée par jean
francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique des
mouvements de grève dans les maisons de
retraite publiques mardi après un
important mouvement de grève dans les
établissements pénitentiaires et puis
les hôpitaux publics qui bouge un peu
est-ce que l'on assiste à la fin d'un
état de grâce pour l'exécutif
je ne sais pas sur l'état de grâce et je
pense que pour ce qui relève des maisons
de retraite et des hôpitaux on arrive au
bout d'un système
c'était le cas aussi sans doute
dans les prisons mais pour rob les
maisons de retraite et les hôpitaux les
conditions de travail se dégradent on
sait qu'on a un financement l'hôpital
qui est absurde puisque conduit à
multiplier les actes et réduire la durée
de séjour et qu'au bout du compte ça se
fait au détriment des conditions de
travail des personnels soignants et
administratifs mais aussi au détriment
des conditions d'accueil dans les
hôpitaux ce qui est des maisons de
retraite
ça fait longtemps que j'en parle j'avais
même formulé des propositions moment de
la campagne présidentielle qui
concernait aussi bien le reste à charge
pour les familles ce qu'il reste à payer
quand on veut peut être soi-même
hébergeant ce d'une maison de retraite
prise en charge notamment quand on a on
est atteint de maladies qui font ne
peuvent être des maladies lourdes comme
les maladies d'alzheimer et qu'on ait de
moins en moins autonome et reste à
charge aussi très important pour les
familles nokia cette question du reste à
charge
1500 euros à peu près mais moi il reste
pour le savoir une famille sur deux ou
un résident sur deux une fois qu'il a
consommé toutes les aides auxquelles il
a le droit
une famille sur deux est bien là reste à
charge qui suppose qu'on aille où puiser
dans ses économies ou demander à ses
enfants de pouvoir prendre en charge
votre accueil dans une maison de
retraite ce qui est parfois très
humiliant pour des personnes qui sont
accueillis en maison de retraite et au
delà de cela parce qu'ils étaient mus
millions aujourd'hui est ce qu'on
découvre quand même si c'est vraiment la
tasse grandeur quelques que lui donne la
presse aujourd'hui c'est la souffrance
la maltraitance mais alors partons de
lire mais les grands médias aujourd'hui
met en lumière quelque chose que l'on
connaît depuis pas mal d'années et
notamment la dégradation des conditions
de travail
pourquoi parce que globalement le nombre
de personnes qui travaillent dans les
maisons de retraite n'a pas changé d'un
établissement à un autre
sauf que les personnes qui entrent et
entrent de plus en plus âgée et donc de
moins en moins autonome et donc les
besoins qui sont ceux de ses résidents
sont plus importants et on à la
description aujourd'hui crues brutales
de la réalité non seulement des
conditions de travail mais aussi des
conditions dans lesquelles vivent ces
personnes quand on absents tenait le
mouvement ah oui mais je vais prendre un
temps mort il a complètement mais je le
soutenais temps plus que pendant la
campagne présidentielle je relatais déjà
ces exemples où une toilette qui devrait
être fait en 20 25 minutes c'est ce
qu'on apprend quand on fait un diplôme
professionnel pour aller travailler
ensuite en maison de retraite
ces toilettes dans les faits en dix
minutes on apprend qu'une personne qui a
besoin de couches pardon quand elle est
un continent tu es bien on la change
plus toutes les quatre heures comme on
doit le faire et toutes les huit heures
et ces personnes qui travaillent sont
souvent des femmes dans les maisons de
retraite vous dise en travaillant mal au
manque à la dignité parfois la plus
élémentaire à l'égard des résidents
ce qui est en jeu c'est l'idée que l'on
se fait du grand âge du vieillissement
et parfois aussi la fin de vie je crois
que pour cela il faudrait un plan de
recrutement moi j'en ferais connaissait
bien financé par l'assurance maladie
s'est parfaitement endossable
aujourd'hui on a des comptes publics qui
le permettent
il s'agit que de quelques centaines de
millions d'euros rendez vous compte on
convient de faire je prends toujours cet
exemple mais il faut toujours mettre les
choses en regard qu'elle quel était
l'intérêt de baisser l'impôt sur la
fortune de 4 milliards quand on sait que
quelques centaines de millions d'euros
permettrait de faire un plan de
recrutement et si vous rajoutez un
milliard supplémentaire de diminuer le
reste à charge pour l'immense majorité
des familles pour les maisons de
retraite faut mettre en balance les
choix politiques qui sont faits alors on
nous dit un jour vous verrez les
résultats de ces deux cadeaux qui a été
fait aux plus riches parce que vous
finirez bien par gober quelques gouttes
de ce ruisseau helmand kirara ira
jusqu'à vous met immédiatement on voit
qu'aujourd'hui on a un système qui est à
bout de souffle
c'est valable de beauty pour l'hôpital
public eh bien il faudrait je veux pas
parler de grands mots comme les états
généraux grenelle tout ça veut rien dire
en clair aujourd'hui la question de
l'avenir l'hôpital public et la prise en
charge des personnes âgées est en jeu et
il faudra une mobilisation générale sur
ces questions ça ne coûte pas très cher
ça ne coûte pas très cher et il y va de
la dignité et des gens qui y travaillent
et des gens qui y sont reçus
est-ce que vous pensez que sur sur sur
ces questions
le mac on sera aussi ferme qu'il l'a été
sur les prisons par exemple je sais pas
s'il a été ferme
je pense qu'il y ait sur les prisons il
a fermé la porte à dire oui si on
supplémentaire est d'ailleurs maintenant
le conflit c'est violent
mais le confie si l'enclavé remettez à
payer le problème des prisons c'est
évidemment le 1er des gardiens et c'est
le problème des détenus nous sommes
régulièrement condamnée pour ne pas
respecter les règles minimum en matière
de surpopulation carcérale
nous sommes régulièrement condamnée pour
ne pas respecter les droits de l'homme
en prison peut considérer que c'est tout
à fait marginale mais on mesure l'état
d'une civilisation à la manière dont
elle traite ses prisonniers c'est comme
ça que en tout cas à mes yeux il
faudrait avancer et avance en disant
quoi pour les prisons que la meilleure
manière de régler le problème et des
gardiens de prisons et de ceux qui sont
condamnés ce serait de développer les
peines alternatives qui évite de mettre
en prison des gens dont on sait qu'en
les mettant en prison pour des courtes
peines
ils risquent de sortir plus dangereux de
prison qu'il n'y était une solution de
devenir leader en liga entre guillemets
les prisons mais pas dans ton idée je
pense aujourd'hui qu'il faut développer
ce que veut ce qu'avait proposé déjà
christiane taubira les peines de
substitution mais sur l'hôpital et les
maisons de retraite
nous verrons sur cette question là ce
qui est le sens de l'intérêt général lee
président de la république parce que
s'ils ne voient pas que sur l'hôpital
public comme sur les maisons de retraite
se joue l'idée qu'on se fait du vivre
ensemble bien davantage que dans tous
les dossiers qu'il a traités jusqu'à
présent pas simplement un hôpital qui
soigne bien guéri bien mais un hôpital
dans lequel on doit apprendre aussi à ne
pas tomber malade et ça me laisse abuser
vous que le système est à bout de
souffle et moi je dis qu'il faut en
finir avec la tarification à l'activité
remettront-ils en cause
l'hôpital entreprise qui juge un service
selon sa performance sa performance et
en mesurer à ce qu'on appelle la durée
moyenne de séjour qu'il faut réduire mon
pouvoir multiplier les actes eh bien je
ne nous verrons là dessus s'ils uni il
engage une vraie réforme de l'hôpital
public
et s'il est moins obsédé à l'idée de
plaire à la commission européenne au
moment de ré de rendre les comptes
publics de la france qui l'amène à
réduire à peu près dans tous les
domaines la dépense publique
ou s'il prend la mesure aujourd'hui de
ce que devrait être et bien le degré de
civilisation et de dignité que l'on doit
mais alors dans la préparation de
l'avenir vous dites que le chef de
l'état cherche à plaire à la commission
européenne est enfin là il essaye
d'appliquer les règles à la france
d'ailleurs la france va repasser sous la
barre des 3% de déficit le premier temps
au prix on a pu d'hôpital public mais on
est passé sous les 3 points
alors écoutez justement bravo emmanuel
navon alors écouter ce que dit le
commissaire européen pierre moscovici un
qui fait de vos amis rythme il impose
comme emmanuel macron alors juste
déconné de mort mais l'hôpital public
mais bravo pierre moscovici il lui
demande même de faire mieux écouter ce
qui dit elle ne faut pas relâcher
l'effort budgétaire la france doit
montrer l'exemple
la france va mieux elle va mieux sur le
plan de ses déficits a tenus sur le plan
de sa croissance et elle va mieux du
point de vue de ses déséquilibres
mais la france doit viser très haut la
france doit viser la première phrase
place mails macron veux être et je le
soutiens là dessus le leader en europe
et pour être le leader en europe
il faut montrer l'exemple alors montré
l'exemple en matière de déficit est
vraiment mais en fait on n'est pas
d'accord sur la maladie avec ce genre de
scénarios de politique on peut mourir
guéri passionnante mourir guéri mais on
meurt quand même à la fin ce qui est en
jeu c'est veux-t-on avoir un grand
hôpital public
peut-on avoir une politique de prise en
charge du grand âge à la hauteur de
l'idée qu'on se fait de la dignité des
femmes et des hommes
c'est ça qui doit nous conduire c'est ça
qui fait qu'on fait de la politique on
fait pas de la politique en disant tiens
je vais faire 0% de déficit ça n'a pas
de sens et / la croissance pour
l'économie du pays
j'observe plateau la france les services
la croissance et les médiocres dans
l'europe depuis longtemps qu'on a
moi je veux bien tout ça ça fait 30 ans
qu'on fait son temps ça fait 40 ans que
les différents volets maintenant 40 ans
a fait 40 1940 les déficits publics se
creusent et que le service public se
rend compte qu est ce que la de votre
raisonnement
le bug c'est quoi c'est qu'on a le
chômage de masse le bug c'est qu'on n'a
pas la croissance le bug c'est que
l'hôpital public c'est de la merde parce
qu'on n'a pas de marge de manoeuvre
budgétaire mais vous rentrez dans un
climat politique non pas de la même
manière non à ce qui me préoccupe moi
mais c'est non mais c'est pas de
l'économie on vous en fait si vous
faites de l'économie n'en fait pas de la
bonne puisque à la fin en fait pas de
croissance et on a toujours du chômage
et des inégalités qui se creusent donc
vous faites de l'économie mais c'est
l'économie c'est pas la science exacte
et j'observe que les théories que
défendre votre journal et que vous
défendez en soutenant d'ailleurs
largement les choix de monsieur
moscovici ou de monsieur mâcon sont pas
des théories qui marchent en présérie de
l'alma oui mais quel est le taux de
pauvreté en allemagne mais je prends les
paris ils est bien supérieur là je
comprends qu'il est 9 17% et en france
il est de 14
donc on peut on peut aussi avoir comme
objectif de se dire bon comment on fait
pour réduire la pauvreté réduire les
inégalités leur juste mesure
je préfère vous par là c'est une
question qui nous amène à la fiche de
paye jeu d'ailleurs du mois de janvier
absolument l'an passé il va augmenter un
peu puisque la différence entre le
salaire net et le salaire brut va
diminuer le salaire net augmente un peu
sur les de de paye du mois de
janvier en raison de la diminution voire
de la suppression des cotisations
maladie et d'écouter son cheval est ce
que c'est une bonne mesure
côté pour le celui qui bénéficie de la
gamme pouvoir d'achat oui derrière la
question c'est comment finance-t-on
notre modèle social dont on dit qu'il
faut qu'ils fonctionnent à la
flexsécurité j'espère qu'on parlera de
l'avenir de l'assurance chômage puisque
on va mettre sous contrôle maintenant
les chômeurs après avoir rendu plus
facile de licenciement des travailleurs
donc d or dans ce travail met donc le
sol il est positif que du positif pour
les salariés du privé
reste à voir pour le public reste à voir
pour les retraités dont vous savez que
l'immense majorité pour le public nommé
non mais les retraités viennent de voir
baisser leur pension et sachez quand
même que ce dont on parle c'est pas des
pensions énorme ou
br 30 euros par moins 20 euros par mois
à 40,50 euros pour des gens qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie parfois très
tôt et voient leur pension bce parce
qu'ils n'ont aucune compensation
ils ont l'augmentation de la csg mais
pas de baisse des cotisations ce qui ne
travaillent plus donc on parle de la
solidarité intergénérationnelle sympa
mais qui fait qu' il met à la mode quand
même qu'ils exerçaient solidarité avec
messieurs bolloré et compagnie qui
viennent tous d'avoir 4 milliards
d'euros d'il y est c'est fait c'est
marrant comme la solidarité c'est
valable pour les uns mais pas pour les
autres
donc nous conduit ce que je lui demande
juste c'est quand même assez frappant
qu'on est en tête c'est l'observatoire
français des conjonctures économiques de
vous rapporter souvent les travaux qui
montrent que j'ai eu des réformes
fiscales elles ont entraîné des gains
pour des personnes les 5% de français
les plus riches se sont accaparés 42%
des gains des réformes fiscales emmanuel
macron à côté de ça on va mettre en
place le contrôle des chômeurs on baisse
les apl
on supprime les contrats aidés qui
étaient souvent des pauvres un pardon
qui occupaient ces métiers là c'est dur
coup pour les uns c'est de la monnaie de
singe et pour les autres c'est du
sonnant et trébuchant
moi je pense que c'est là le prince de
l'injustice de vous demander l'état de
grâce des manuels macro chose que j'ai
pas tellement vite commenté ça je pense
que il est agile il est intelligent et
sait et ça peut durer mais le fait est
que ces politiques elles ont des
conséquences dans la vie quotidienne de
bon nombre de français d'une majorité de
français et que ses conséquences
immédiatement ou à terme les amèneront à
être plus vulnérables avoir un horizon
beaucoup plus à court terme qui ne
l'était avant et avoir moins de chance
de gravir justement une place
supplémentaire dans l'échelle sociale
parle beaucoup de mérite
je pense que quel que soit le mérite des
gens qui sont les plus pauvres
aujourd'hui c'était là c'est beaucoup
plus dur avec le type de réforme qui est
mise en oeuvre depuis maintenant laissez
moi est ce que ce n'est pas selon vous
la limite du et de droite et de gauche
c'est à dire que et de droite on
attendait et menace maintenant choléra
croire milk est de gauche on l'attendait
davantage dans la réforme sociale mais
est ce que vous dites est ce que vous
trouvez un une personne de gauche qui
vous dit emmanuel fatma kron fait ce
qu'on aurait aimé faire
vous entendez des gens droits dire
emmanuel macron fait ce qu'on aurait
aimé faire pas le contraire bon qu'après
eux emmanuel macron il a levé une
imposture incontestablement l'idée selon
laquelle le clivage droite gauche situé
entre le parti socialiste et les
républicains en réalité on mesure que le
clivage droite gauche dans la vie
politique française se situer sans doute
au coeur du parti socialiste entre ceux
qui aujourd'hui se sentent bien avec une
politique de droite d'emmanuel mâcon et
ceux qui ne se sentent pas bien avec
cette politique là mais il propose une
autre imposture le fait qu'il n'y ait
plus de clivage
mais les clivages il repousse sur des
choses simples on n'a pas tous les mêmes
intérêts on peut y travailler on peut
même rechercher des compromis mais dans
la vie on se rend compte aujourd'hui pas
que quand on va à l'hôpital public où
que l'on va dans une clinique privée on
n'a pas forcément les mêmes intérêts
quand on dirige parfois une grande un
grand groupe ou quand on est patron de
pme on n'a pas forcément les mêmes
intérêts aujourd'hui il y à des conflits
et il y aura donc toujours une vision de
l'égalité la liberté même du vivre
ensemble de gauche ou droite c'est pas
mal
alors c'est la démocratie le dire que ça
n'existe plus et une impossible une
impossible à la posture aujourd'hui
repasser le baccalauréat quatre épreuves
plus un grand oral la suppression des
filières s es l s que c'est une baisse
que ça va dans le bon sens a encore je
serai prudent mais je vais pas condamner
cette réforme
a priori je serai prudent parce que le
point sur lequel je serai attentif comme
tout le monde sait les conditions dans
lesquelles la part du contrôle continu
well ne crée pas d'inégalité
supplémentaires on sait déjà qu'il ya
des inégalités selon les lycées dans
lesquels vous allez collèges etc
mais si le contrôle continu finalement
creux ces inégalités ce serait un
problème mais il me semble aujourd'hui
que
bon voilà la réforme de coop peut-être
entendu je regarderai ça avec intérêt
j'ajoute une chose pas d'hostilité de
principe j'ai pas d'hostilité principe
j'ai une réserve je rajoute une deuxième
que j'aimerais que la ministre de
l'éducation nationale entende
allez faut pas que le passeport ce soit
un certificat de fin d'études seulement
notamment pour les bacheliers pro vie
bacheliers technos faut que ce soit
toujours un pass'sport pour l'université
et pour la poursuite d'études
or aujourd'hui quand on fait le lien
entre la réforme du baccalauréat et la
sélection à l'entrée de l'université
j'ai peur qu'en fait on pour suivre
cette idée selon laquelle parce qu'on
n'a pas envie de mettre de moyen dans
l'université toujours les mêmes
problèmes de déficit on veut pas mettre
les 5 milliards dont on aurait besoin
dans ce pays tout le monde le dit c'est
5 milliards sur cinq ans eh bien on
ferme la porte aux bacheliers pros aux
bacheliers technos faut pas que ce soit
le but voilà une porte permet de plus
est ce que dans la sphère barman à le
ministre visé par une plainte pour viol
doit démissionner selon vous oui ou non
écoutez moi je vais prendre l'exemple ou
de l'organisation dans laquelle je suis
nous quand on a eu une plainte pour
seule agression sexuelle à l'époque et
harcèlement nous avons demandé à la
personne visée par cette plainte de se
démettre est en tout cas de sous
traitent burgio oui voilà ce qu'il y à
tout responsable des mesures au sein du
gouvernement un rapport à la démission
forcée très rapide c'est
incontestablement il ya dans certains
cas eu des enquêtes qui conduisent à des
démissions d'autres pas d'émission moi
je suis pas j'observe le cas une
distinction en tout cas et que le
j'imagine que edouard philippe doit être
très sûr du cas qu'il défend pour dire
qu'il maintiendra au dessus armand sa
confiance à monsieur darmanin après je
vois la note comme tout le monde qu'il
ya effectivement
deux types de situation l'une pour
lesquels cela justifie qu'on soit démis
pour monsieur bayrou madame e ou la
goulard voilà ou de sarnez monsieur
ferrand et dans l'autre cas quand il
s'agit d'une accusation de viol c'est
pas le cas
le temps la justice doit faire son
travail je le dis d'autant plus parce
que nous avons décidé de prendre des
décisions prendre des décisions sur le
cac qui concernait une personne que je
connaissais les gardois rayonnant panien
de près ouais mais bon qui n'étaient pas
en l'occurrence le viol dont vous n'avez
pas la main oui mais mais on l'a pris en
décidant de rendre au public nous mêmes
je rappelle que c'est en octobre
moi même alors il décide de rendre
publique cette affaire évidemment sans
dévoiler l'identité des plaignantes pour
les protéger les victimes
mais moi ma fierté je vais vous dire
c'est que des femmes dans l'organisation
que je dirige prennent la parole se
mobilisent met en place des formes
d'organisation qui permettent de
prévenir cela aide à former à informer
on est en train de franchir un stade en
terme de maturité sur ces questions qui
moi me réjouis j'ai plus envie de parler
des victimes que
de ceux qui sont responsables présumés
innocents toujours mes responsables
peut-être de faits de harcèlement
d'agression galets deuxième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité benoît hamon on va
parler de votre mouvement générations et
c'est lucile qui vous pose la question
alors vous voulez que votre mouvement
génération soit la première force de
progrès en france mais on voit beaucoup
jean luc mélenchon on le présente
facilement comme le premier opposant
quel espace vous laisse-t-il et comment
vous en sortir alors que lui à un groupe
de 17 députés et vous non ecoutez jean
luc mélenchon quand il était quand
l'élection présentielle n'était pas
député le fait qu'elles soient députés
ou pas député c'est pas un discriminant
fondamental parce que je crois c'est que
l'élection présidentielle n'est pas très
loin quand même à crosne même pas fait
un hangar et sa trace à venir pour
bosser maintenu mais j'ai dit mais elle
n'est pas loin et on a skié de la
social-démocratie connu une déroute
historique
donc le fait de reconstituer aujourd'hui
des forces politiques qui tient les
leçons de cela moi je me suis attaché à
faire un inventaire pas simplement des
responsabilités des autres et compris
des miennes dans la campagne
présidentielle
des choix politiques qu'on a fait le
fait qu'aujourd'hui je maintienne le cas
par exemple sur le revenu universel on
pourra dire mais abandonné l'idée
n'était pas populaire on va en parler
avant par là mais elle est encore moins
claires aujourd'hui vous verrez ben non
on va en parler planeur on a un sondage
oui mais je le connais votre sont d'un
cantine vous n'avez pas d'amis cno mais
non non je fais pas je sais pas le
premier sous le petit nom me fait
vraiment honneur de compter mais
l'inventaire fait un mea culpa c'est de
regarder ski dont nous échec doit nous
apprendre les leçons qu'on peut en tirer
et je peux vous assurer que le revenu
universel votre sondage au contraire me
réjouis parce que cette idée il ya un an
lenval duane reade vient plus
impopulaire qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui
alors on à la question mais est-ce que
vous êtes favorable à la nomination d'un
revenu universel en donne les chiffres
puisque les commente un donc opinionway
disait 600 800 euros de la naissance à
la mort donc il y a
34% de personnes favorables 63% josé et
l'écart se creuse en fait entre les pour
et les contres dans ce sondage est
patent des si vous prenez l'idée il y a
un nom du revenu universel d'existence
elie et maintenant les progrès sont
considérables même dans l'opinion avant
l'idée s'est installé comme une question
sociale puis bon je serais bien curieux
de savoir qui il ya deux ans posé la
question de ceux du revenu universel
parce que avant que j'en parle dans le
débat public
évidemment il y avait des associations
il y avait des acteurs mais c'était un
sujet qui était on va dire à ces
périphériques dans le domaine public et
on progresse et autour de quoi d'une
idée qui va s'enraciner et qui peut
d'ailleurs peut-être nous réunir c'est
que le travail est en train de se
métamorphoser qu'il faudra penser aussi
un nouveau contrat social parce qu'on ne
pourra plus financer une protection
sociale d'une sécurité sociale
seulement sur le travail quand on sait
par exemple que les cotisations
patronales sont adossés sur le nombre de
salariés vous avez je prends un exemple
simple vous avez une entreprise qui fait
10 millions de chiffre d'affaires avec
200 salariés une autre qui ont fait 10
millions avec 20 salariés y en a une qui
celle qui a 200 salariés qui va payer
dix fois plus donc ça sa cotisation à
reste le coeur de notre positionnement
solide trio thé la question grave que la
révolution numérique est en train comme
aucune étude ne le conteste sérieusement
aujourd'hui de transformer le travail de
conduire à ce que dans certains secteurs
ce sont des centaines de milliers des
millions d'emplois qui vont se
transformer voir disparaître ce qu'il
faudra donc en créer des nouveaux mais
vu que les transformations qui s'opèrent
il me semble logique que l'on pense
l'avenir notre sécurité sociale en
mettant à contribution les entreprises
non pas en fonction du nombre de
salariés qu'elle vaut mais de la
richesse qu'elle va revenir les larmes
et les deux 10 millions si elles font 10
millions de chiffre d'affaires et
doivent payer les mêmes cotisations à
leur départ vers là et pas dix fois plus
pour celle qu'a de son salarié est dix
fois moins 300 rien à voir faire la
campagne présidentielle va bien on a
bien entendu vos arguments et les
questions de lutte il était peut-être
plus politique sur les questions
d'alliances ont fait 2 et notamment pour
les européennes par exemple pour les
européennes on voit bien que à gauche
il va y avoir beaucoup de monde que
chacun peut partir tout seul ou qu' il
peut y avoir des alliances alors de
votre côté quels sont les alliances que
vous envisagez ce que c'est plutôt avec
les écologistes les communistes avec la
france insoumise moi je ne pose aucun
prêt là pour l'instant je travaille avec
diane histoire
les français les grecs
il est l'ancien ministre financo nominés
des finances de la grèce au moment de
mes parents sans la rabroue au conflit
avec la banque la banque centrale
européenne et le fonds monétaire
international notamment est notre point
identique
nous disons que nous pouvons nous
voulons porter un projet européen est
alors le train et tout est en marche et
qui veut nous rejoindre nous rejoignent
qui au lendemain d'élections européennes
lundi matin 9h moment les portes de la
commission ouvre les portes du parlement
européen où on puisse être portée et mis
en oeuvre à traiter constant par une
nouvelle majorité au parlement européen
ce que nous voulons c'est dire que
aujourd'hui la la poursuite des
politiques d'austérité va précipiter la
désintégration de l'europe et je pense
que ce que propose le couple merkel
macron qui n'est rien d'autre que le
prolongement de ce qui se fait depuis 10
20 ans si on ne voit pas qu'il est en
train de désintégrer l'europe
eh bien on est aveugle première chose
mais je pense que la réponse 1 ce qui
serait pendant de dire revenons aux
frontières nationales jetons l'europe
avec ce libéralisme maudit mènera aussi
à une autre forme de désintégration dont
je prouve qu'elle n'est pas souhaitable
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
porterons ensemble on y travaille c'est
pas encore définitif on est sur le fond
là aujourd'hui mais probablement s'ils
ne les adhérents et les membres de deux
générations l'approuvent
en juin prochain mais nous voulons
porter un projet qui soit applicable au
lendemain même de l'élection européenne
et qui disent on peut parfaitement
aujourd'hui mener des politiques qui ne
soit pas austérité en europe tout en
restant très européen à traiter quand ça
c'est très important ce que vous des
tapas et écouter ce que disait ce matin
sur public sénat clémentine autain qui
est député la france insoumise et qui
est là bas souligne justement sa
divergence fondamentale avec avec vous
sur l'europe at il dit je prends un
exemple mais quand il dit on peut
réformer l'europe dans le cadre de ces
traités moi je ne le crois pas je pense
que nous avons besoin de bousculer cette
europe est de sortir de ces traités là
c'est pour que c'est en effet une
divergence
fruit clément sinon au charme propose de
modifier les traités mais n'annonce en
rien être est ce que nous proposerons
surcreusement merino épandeur élabore
veut pas dire ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne veut pas les modifier un pan
des lunes amateur et je vais lui
répondre très précisément
nous nous voulons dire tout ce que nous
ferons à traiter constant et évidemment
désirer les modifier pour par exemple
démocratiser la zone euro mais en tenant
compte des délais qu'il faut aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir changer ses traités je
connais clémentine autain a dit je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse le faire a traité
constants donc il faut changer les
traités en l'état qui pensent
sérieusement 12 secondes que l'europe va
s'aligner sur les positions de la gauche
française possible possible mais
peut-être jeu français sera peut-être
pas tout seul bon d'accord mais là en
l'occurrence si auch que je comprends
bien ce sont nos positions en tout cas
celle de clémentine autain qui devrait
ouvrir sur une nouvelle europe
moi je n'y crois pas ce que ça veut dire
pour autant que on ne faut pas invité la
france a soumises à ce qu'à construire
un rapport de force même qu'il vienne
mais qu'ils viennent et qu'on construise
un rapport de force où on s'approche le
plus possible à traiter constant à bord
prenant un exemple concret la banque
centrale européenne fait des politiques
de quantitative easing
en clair elle injecte de l'argent dans
l'économie européenne pour faciliter les
conditions dans lesquelles les banques
vont pouvoir prêter de l'argent aux
entreprises elles leur assoupli les
conditions dans lesquelles elles prêtent
aux entreprises
cette politique a amené la banque
centrale européenne depuis 2015 a
injecté plus de 2000 milliards d'euros
en europe dans l'économie européenne
plus de 2000 milliards d'euros c'est pas
rien la question est à traiter constant
donc ne peut-on pas fléché une partie de
cette politique de quantitative easing
injection d'argent frais dans l'économie
européenne vers la transition écologique
et qu'on me dise surtout c'est la
question que je repose à clémentine
autain abel est pas là pour vos réponses
oui mais vous me répondrez qu'on vous
l'inviterai après aimé n comment fait-on
demain alors qu'il ya urgence écologique
pour opérer la conversion de notre
modèle de développement avec cette
conversion soit utile pour éviter un
scénario de réchauffement qu'ils soient
à court terme périlleux pour les
générations futures
comment le fait aussi on sort on
rapatrie van hove à dire tout haut
niveau national ça voudra dire que on
abandonne là
le perspective qu'il y a d'être utile au
climat c'est à dire d'agir au niveau
européen il n'y a qu'au niveau européen
ne parviendra à changer les règles du
jeu en matière de modèle de
développement notamment pour lucky
country une question à vous soumettre
ses fautes celle que opinionway a posé
c'est la deuxième question de la semaine
sur les alliances justement et après on
parlera justement de ceux qui sont
notamment cités dans ce sondage
vos amis anciens amis du parti
socialiste avec qui conduire votre offre
alternative a demandé au pivot
opinionway avec les écologistes 18% avec
le ps 17% avec la france insoumise 16%
avec aucun 54% les français dans leur
majorité vous encourage à rester
autonome même si chez les sympathisants
de gauche est bien le premier choix et
qui est cité c'est la france insoumise à
38%
voilà avec 34 pour les écologistes
qu'est ce que vous voulez comme que je
règle pour eux tendance et d'être ne
rester autonome non mais je connais un
grand bouleversement est que dans les
sous c'est pas très ouverte à d à une
union oui donc - les appareils auxquels
moi je m'adresser ou ceux qui les
représentent comme que les citoyens les
les personnes engagées et objectivement
nous sommes toujours dans un moment
d'histoire opn séparez vous allez
diviser les votes c'est sûr on va
dépendre des visions sont des visions
différentes de l'europe sans doute et on
l'avait vu dès l'élection présidentielle
moi je me revendique comme européen et
fédéralistes et je pense qu'ils ont eue
je crois en la coopération entre les
peuples
je ne veux pas renoncer à cette idée là
je ne veux pas renoncer à l'idée que
demain même si c'est un parfait même si
c'est libéral par la démocratie on
arrivera à mettre en oeuvre des
politiques de progrès certains pensent
je le regrette d'ailleurs que j'entends
leurs arguments que par nature l'europe
il n'emmènera que régression mais moi je
pense que non il faut créer un espace de
solidarité ces lettres dernière utopie
l'europe est un peu vivante et le pire
des choses ce serait de la jetée aux
orties libéral avec maquereau ou
conservatrice avec macro et merkel
ou alors la jetée aux orties
ben nationalisme au madame le pen ou
souverainistes et parce que ce serait le
plus beau projet alors il a été dévoyé
il est aujourd'hui à mon avis il se
retourne contre les peuples européens
il nous reste à mettre de la démocratie
et du sens au projet européen moi j'y
crois à traiter constants est ce que je
le répète pour que les oreilles
s'échauffent pas ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne veut pas modifier les traités
nous proposerons doit le faire mais nous
avons un plan à très bientôt
là la situation politique en france
foyer le ps est mort a dit ce lundi
matin
manuel valls est ce que la mission à le
tuer notez bien est ce que vous y avez
contribué un peu aussi quand il ya des
principes moi j'ai été choisi par une
primaire citoyenne
plus de 2000 il n'y avait pas besoin
résultat 2 6% on en met d'accord et ça
commence par soi même une responsabilité
aussi dans les sécrétions parti je
n'esquive pas mais vous observerez que
vous avez causé su dans un processus où
la social-démocratie s'effondre partout
en europe et dans des conditions qui
sont absolument spectaculaire banal mais
le ps est mort quand son armada
allemagne que vous connaissez mal
monsieur pécresse c'est le plus mauvais
score le permis mais elle est formelle
mais c'est peut pas simplement être
encore dans tu ne collait pas peut-être
dans une coalition de groupes parfois
des pétrins par les conservateurs on
vous entendez plus à sociale des gens
parlant du ps parlant donc je j'observe
qu'il ne gagne plus non plus depuis
qu'ils s'allient à la droite de caisse
en france il est mort non moi je dû
écouter non le parc société jeu l'équité
c'est pas pour parler du parti
socialiste donc je vais être scellée en
fait vous le dis c'est pour que vous
êtes et non mais aucun choix mais alors
là je serai en plus imiterait inélégant
vous savez qu'on liquide et halo nistos
parti socialisme et je m'en réjouis
elle est venue dire qu'elle mènerait
probablement ailleurs les hamonistes
sons sont très dispersées entre le
candidat à l'exception des fans ou alors
je veux maintenant car vous n'êtes
aujourd'hui moi je suis un nouveau
mouvement politique
cinquante mille morts plus de cinquante
mille membres aujourd'hui dans ce
nouveau mouvement politique
plus les mois passent copé à sanary bah
écoutez je ne livre pas des comparaisons
mais en tout cas nous nous remplissons
les salles
et partout en france et que nous sommes
sur une dynamique
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire je
peux vous parler de ce que je connais
aujourd'hui j'ai pas envie de vous
parler les textes ne les ai pas lues
genou je vous avoue je ne lirai pas
avant non mais c'est pas là je ne suis
plus au parti socialiste que l'entrée
comme à des candidats sous votre
étiquette à des élections partielles en
des élections par goût ou à des
élections locales d'ailleurs on connaît
la question s'est posée
jusqu'à présent nous n'avons pas jugé
mais c'est nécessaire de le faire c'est
non parce que l énergie d'abord le
mouvement politique qu'il faut qu'il
s'inscrit il veut dans la vie publique
ça met du temps et un nouveau mouvement
c'est pas en trois mois qu il est
identifié moi je suis identifié sans
doute le mouvement pas encore donc notre
priorité c'est vraiment de consolider
développer ce mouvement et sur des
campagnes dont je vous parlais la
question des ehpad l'hôpital nous a dit
qu'il fallait faire l'objet d'une grande
campagne lors impossible évidemment les
questions européennes mais aussi des
questions centrales à gauche sur lequel
j'entends pas beaucoup de voix à gauche
la question des migrants voilà on entend
des associations a entendu condamner le
gouvernement en termes vifs mais oui moi
je le fais comme homme de gauche
j'observe que les voix à gauche ont des
trois ou plus nous avons entendu dans
une profession de foi européenne à ses
vibrantes il ya quelques instants mais
j'ai toujours été comme souvent c'est
vous c'est très émotionnel européens
mais pas pour nous précise qu'il allait
conduire à un défaut démocratique
haguenau faille démocratique avait
prédit judiciable à l'europe d'accord
vous avez vibré sur leur pour l'europe
il ya un instant que pensez vous du
projet d'emmanuel macron qui rassemblait
de ceux justement sur l'europe de cohn
bendit à juppé quant à elle même plus
loin c'est bien le peuple a justement
jusqu'aux plus large mais écoutez 9 ce
que vous vous serez dans le camp des
anti européens non mais je pense que
emmanuel macron rassemble très bien des
gens qui vont bien et bien portant ce
qui pose régulièrement leur séant sur le
joli fauteuils en velours bien
confortable héééé que ce rassemblement
des bien portants réunira les voix des
bien portants moi j'aspire à ce que
beaucoup de biens portants qui
s'intéressent à l'intérêt général à la
cohésion de la société à la manière dont
on se préoccupe pas simplement de ceux
qui vont bien
j'aspire à aller rassemblés à les réunir
autour d'un projet européen et
progressistes moi je veux donner du sens
à l'écologie au niveau européen au
progrès social au niveau européen à la
justice et à la démocratie
et je crois que nous allons réussir à le
faire pas simplement avec des français
vous le verrez bien si nous y arrivons
des mêmes candidats voire tête de liste
nous verrons en temps et en heure si je
mène ses listes vous serez pas prise
non j'ai pas du tout décidé cela
aujourd'hui on va continuer à parler
mais ben el madani les têtes de liste on
va continuer à parler des manuels seront
de son leadership et ses deux sa vision
de la mondialisation à laquelle vous
allez pouvoir lui opposer la vôtre
benoît hamon s'est tout de suite
on va écouter le chef de l'état donc
c'était il ya quelques jours bien sûr au
forum économique de davos et il a
expliqué qu'elle était la responsabilité
de la france se réformer mais aussi
défendre une certaine vision de la
mondialisation construire une danse ans
prospère et ouverte au monde mais
capables de reconnaître et d'accepter et
d'intégrer les laissés pour compte de la
mondialisation parce que septembre est
cette chose il faut pouvoir se montrer
plus de classe que c'est qu'elle est
plus équitable pour les classes moyennes
en même temps alors il n'a pas parlé là
que des gens bien portants comme vous
dites dans l'océan est posé sur du
velours rouge vraiment mais il fait de
très beaux discours je lui ai donné je
n'ai pas écouté sur la rd sous fond de
teint mais y ait pas d un il ya les mots
pour les autres ça direct et le
président de la république et c'est
votre rôle de journaliste que de le
constater ou pas de faire l'inventaire
de ce qui se fait ce qui se fait pas fin
de la taxe sur les transactions
financières baisse de l'indicé sf flat
tax sur le capital pour les uns et pour
les autres c'est quoi ce sont les autres
c'est quoi c'est mais des miettes et
bien les deux layettes charlie st
l'augmenter sur le pouvoir d'achat sur
le long terme et on en parlait il ya
créé ces sont des miettes électivement
on a des grands enjeux on à l'école
aujourd'hui c'est d'un point sur
lesquelles on va là cette fois ci pas
être d'accord est monsieur bancaire mais
on a fait douze élèves par classe dans
les zones d'éducation prioritaire au cp
comment on va faire douze élèves par
classe en ce1 sinon délire en allant
prendre des postes ailleurs là où on va
augmenter le nombre d'élèves par classe
dans le reste de la france
je pense que cette obsession parce que
benoît inconsistent mais on a
l'impression que vous considérez que ce
sont des mesures catégorielles pour les
riches en fait chez emmanuel macron il
ya cette idée un avion des mesures pour
trouver par remettre en mouvement
l'économie française j'ai progressé
dieu pécresse et revenir du coup film
interroge ou est ce qui m'interroge
quand ils posent ces questions sont ceux
qui bénéficient aujourd'hui sur le plan
fiscal les politiques de monsieur macron
est objectivement on doit être tous dans
les 1 ou 5 % de gens les plus riches et
nous commentons allègrement nous qui
bénéficions donc de ces mesures fiscales
a priori puisque pour ceux qui ont été
son parlement terre on est bien on allie
de nommer ce que j'ai interrogés très
indépendamment de mais ce que je veux
dire relations sexuelles entre autres
heures de votre ordre de priorité les
gens là jour le même nom mais j'ai le
jeu du je te remets ça si je vous parle
pas à vous je sais que j'observe que
c'est toujours la même chose
moi ce que je pense et je la firme dire
comme monsieur castaner l'a fait
qu'aujourd'hui le problème des sans abri
c'est qu'ils refusent des logements pour
derrière faire une circulaire qui remet
en cause un principe sacré de la
république monsieur collomb donc qui est
celui de l'accueil inconditionnel de
celui qui est le plus miséreux et qui a
besoin d'un toit ça nous n'allons plus
le faire où nous ne le ferions plus si
cette circulaire était appliquée au
point que ceux qui s'occupent des
pauvres dans ce pays
dix-sept associations caritatives de
d'emmaüs au secours catholique et la
fondation abbé pierre qui sont quand
même pas des organisations habitué aux
coups d'éclat gauchistes objectivement
elles font leur boulot sur le terrain
font un recours devant le conseil d'état
contre cette circulaire parce qu'elle
est indigne d'un grand pays civilisé
donc avant de faire des grands discours
sur la mondialisation et les
laissés-pour-compte du monde
arrêtons arrêtez monsieur macron arrêtez
monsieur mabut ouvriers de christine et
les droits des laissés pour compte
ici en france quelle que soit leur
origine qu'ils soient français ou
étrangers arrêtés de piétiner leurs
droits et en piétinant leurs droits leur
dignité
à commencer par respecter la dignité des
personnes âgées chez nous fait
mettez sur la table j'y suis prêt moi
puisque à ce qu'on les partis politiques
les associations les syndicats se penche
sur l'avenir de notre modèle de prise en
charge du grand âge travail ou d'enfants
mais on verrait alors sur la régression
par benoît hamon est ce que je veux dire
y avez vous été laissées pour
c'est toujours par les laissés pour
compte par exemple pour être clair
est-ce que vous estimez que la france
doit accueillir comme elle le fait et
comme elle proclame qu'elle continuera à
le faire bien sûr les demandeurs d'asile
qui sont victimes dans leurs crédits de
persécution et faut-il également
accueillir tous les réfugiés économiques
et maintenant mais c'est ça la question
mais non nous s'est passé avec la sepaq
cassidian on vienne louis met d'accord
mais objectivement il ya des gens qui
arrivent parce qu'ils nombreux que ça et
qui viennent ou parce qu'ils sont dans
la misère chez eux ou parce qu'il fut le
rejoignait faut pas faire de différence
ou non mais attendez ici évidemment que
cela il est pour moi renforcer l'asile
ou parce qu'ils fuient les conflits
aujourd'hui la france rennes pour
l'asile dissuade certaines personnes qui
veulent demander l'asile de le faire en
imposant des délais qui nous
correspondent pas à la loi je vous
pourrez vous prendre certains
départements dans lesquels je me suis
rendu ou pour un premier rendez vous là
où la loi impose que ce premier rendez
vous soit au moins fixé dans un délai de
trois à onze jours et il faut plusieurs
mesures afin de réduire le délai à six
musiciens mais pour l'instant pour que
votre dossier soit instruit encore
faut-il pouvoir être enregistrés et bien
pour pouvoir être enregistrés mais
aujourd'hui on ses normes et ses hommes
face à ces conditions les gens de se
faire enregistrer
donc c'est ça la réalité qu'est ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui des grandes voix de
partout au delà de des responsables
politiques dont on pense qu'ils sont
suspects de s'en prendre à emmanuel
macron parce que c'est emmanuel macron
prothèses de cette politique là c'est
qu'elle est indigne de la république et
de la rendre le fait-il alors qu'alex en
glisse à la gestion du monde mais moi
j'ai passé riche en diamants de gérard
collomb et yelp ou vers les associations
pense pas qu'il a répondu ondéron là
dessus pourquoi est ce qu'ils font ça
parce que l'opinion public nous suit oui
au niveau ville
mais souvenons mais basé en pn colonel
emile de rona entend sont en sont mais
non l'allemagne arrêté mais l'allemagne
mais elle a fait d'abord un million de
réfugiés monsieur pécresse j'ai fait ça
donc je vais bien
appris non mais on a appris ça ce qu'est
ce que dizaines de milliers dans notre
île on a pu y vivre ou les mamans à
mener sur ce terrain-là plaignant est ce
qu'un et autant d'allemands mais je
pense quand je m'en vais apprendre
comment fonctionne la crise en allemagne
on a le choix des tice dès le premier
jour en allemagne et une prise en charge
psychologique parce que ces personnes là
sont souvent notamment réalisé me laisse
des mois de l'exil et des traversées
sont très atteinte sur le plan
aujourd'hui on attend mais oui mais est
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'ils ont eu
un ils ont fait un effort considérable
on ferait le quart de cela que ça
provoquerait au sommet des manuels de la
con durand à l'arrêt paris quand même
rendu à la générosité dans gala merkel
vous souvenez il avait dit alors
aujourd'hui vous avez la générosité de
madame merkel pour oublier lui-même
d'être généreux mais moi je lui demande
pas d'être généreux je demandais
président en échange la république qui
respecte les principes de la république
je moi je considère que ce qu'il fait
sur les migrants comparable à la
déchéance de nationalité s'est remise en
cause d'un principe sacré de la
république c'est pas moins alors
peut-être que ça comme ce sont des
migrants comme la en revue comme
aujourd'hui les migrants se dire
aujourd'hui ce qui fait le ciment social
de la nation fait la peur des migrants
et qu'elle est largement alimentée par
les ministres de l'intérieur les uns
après les autres à l'exception de
bernard cazeneuve qui était pas trop sur
ce discours là lui mais beaucoup
d'autres aujourd'hui sont sur un
discours qui est tout systématique de
peur des migrants bon moment je je je
pense que dans ces cas là il faut
revenir aux principes et les principes
m'ordonne de dire au nom des principes
qui sont les miens que aujourd'hui c'est
indigne de faire cela à quelques
milliers de personnes
mais vous dites c'est la déchéance de la
nationalité de françois hollande c'est
vous et certains principes de la
république qui est remis en cause
manuel valls apporte son soutien à qui
bat gérard collomb soutien plein et
entier ça ne vous surprend pas donc
puisque le site est un peu en filigrane
dans la politique vis-à-vis des migrants
oui oui bon j'ai pas tellement a
commenté sur
manuel valls il a eu un mot ce week-end
à la télé il à faire une plaisanterie à
votre sujet sais pas si vous l'avez vu
oui je me l'a dit il a dit pour ne pas
être reconnu dans la rue eh bien je dis
je suis benoît hamon ça vous inspire
quoi
plessis la des câlins se faisant passer
pour moi c'est peut-être que ça lui a
traduit si ça pouvait lui adoucir les
idées seraient par man très bien
prochaine étape pour vous pour votre
mouvement génération benoît hamon vous
avez dit cinquante mille ans prochaine
étape c'est continuer on est mis au défi
de ma de faire face aux demandes
démocratiques d'un mouvement avec autres
membres et sans beaucoup de moyens
aujourd'hui mais mme émond prochaine
étape c'est de continuer à parler à
toute la gauche au mouvement politique
mais aussi aux citoyens parce que après
tout c'est vous c'est votre sondage ça
le disait bien je pense que lui
aujourd'hui on se reconnaît - dans des
parties qui apparaissent comme des
enclos qui ressemble à des enclos
intellectuels politiques ont
l'impression d'être très vite
prisonniers et donc il faut réussir
c'est pas simple d'ailleurs jeudi
très honnêtement j'ai pas là j'ai pas
encore on n'a pas encore forcément
trouvé la recette miraculeuse mais être
horizontale dans le fonctionnement et
démocratique
mais c'est ce que nous tendons à faire
et d'ailleurs je vous annonce la
première innovation démocratique de
notre mouvement ce sera la semaine
prochaine
le tirage au sort qui est déjà fait mail
annonce du seul conseil des membres de
30 membres qui ressort sur les cinquante
mille alors ils sont 3500 à bord a été
candidat sur les cinquante mille
demandes a pas de temps à consacrer pour
venir régulièrement à paris mais ils
seront trente a co dirigé le mouvement
avec la direction de 30 membres donc on
sera 60 ça on verra au sort et ça tourne
tous les ans tous d'accord et c'est un
échantillon représentatif du mouvement
et c'est qu'on les ramenait à la france
insoumise vous en vous envisagez une
école de formation aux militants pas la
formation je prenne tout à fait mais je
pense que c'est une mission centrale et
que là nous avons une la formation on ne
s'en occupe c'est d'ailleurs l'ancien
ministre aurélie filippetti qui s'en
occupera notamment chez nous merci
benoît hamon et la semaine prochaine
notre invité sera marlène schiappa la
secrétaire d'état à l'égalité hommes
femmes merci à vous pour nous d'être là
merci
un beau de dire si ça a très vite
[Musique]